Welcome to this brief
lecture on the basics
of diagnosing the
acromioclavicular,
sternoclavicular and
glenohumeral joints.
Specifically, you will
be tasked to diagnose
these regions for
somatic dysfunction.
So we are
covering the topic
for the purposes
of allowing
you to understand
and therefore
be able to reliably
make osteopathic
diagnoses in
these regions.
Here are the session
objectives, here
are two diagrams on
the bony architecture
of the shoulder.
It does not include
every structure,
the shoulder is a
complicated joint,
it includes soft
tissue components such
as muscles as well
as fascia, the
bursa, and so forth.
On the left we see the
AC, SC, and glenohumeral
joints and how
they are covered by
ligaments or the depiction
of the ligaments.
And it is important to
keep this image in mind.
An important first
step in diagnosing any
complaint, especially
a ****** complaint,
is to ask the patient
where it's located.
It is important
to make a visual
interpretation of the
person's symptoms because
oftentimes a patient
complaining of
shoulder pain may not
necessarily be referring
to the shoulder. On
the left, we see a
picture of a common
region that patients
point to when it comes
to shoulder pain.
And even though this
region is somewhere
between the neck
and the shoulder, it
actually can have its
origins right where the
patient points to
or may involve other
structures such as
the neck, the shoulder
joint, and the upper
back, or even ribcage.
The diagram on the right
shows, for example,
a technique that you
have practiced in
foundations, and it's
just a reminder that
the shoulder, of
course, is a part of the
body, and you see
an outline of the
cervical, thoracic, and
lumbar spine, so it's
important to understand
its proximity and
relationship through
your anatomical
understanding to these
various other regions.
Earlier, I mentioned
that a patient's
shoulder complaint may
actually be caused by
other regions outside
the shoulder, or perhaps
they are contributing
to patient's symptoms
in addition to an
actual problem in the
shoulder. This is where
your history taking
and your comprehensive
physical examination
to include orthopedic
examination, as
well as the neurologic
exam, such as checking
for reflexes,
strength, as well as
sensation along the
various dermatomes related
to the shoulder and
upper extremity are
helpful to help you
decide the origin of a
patient's particular
complaint. These diagrams
just remind you of
important structures
that originate in the
neck, for example,
the nerve structures
that flow through the
shoulder into the
upper extremities. Of
course you have the
circulatory system and
arteries not shown are
the venous system and
lymphatics and of
course soft tissue
structures such as muscles
tendons and fascia.
Now that I have
covered some of the
clinical and anatomical
basics hopefully you
have a better sense
that it is important
to learn your
clinical assessment
skills well and to
combine those with your
osteopathic assessment
skills so that
you can have a more
comprehensive and more
detailed understanding
when applicable
of the origin of a
patient's problems.
We'll start with the
SC joint. So we're
starting from medial
and then we'll progress
laterally to the AC
joint and then the
glenohumeral joint for
somatic dysfunction it
is basically going with
evaluating the same
parameters tissue
texture change asymmetry
range of motion and
tenderness and for these
for the test that's
shown here we are
primarily interested
in the motion
or the lack of motion
in the SC joint.
You stand behind
the patient, but
you can also stand
in front of them.
In either instance, you
want to use your sense
of palpation as well
as observation to
determine which side
moves less well than
expected. And keep in
mind, because these are
bilateral structures both
sides may be involved
as you can see from the
diagram on the bottom
right of the ribcage
sternum and the two
clavicles that you can
almost think of the
clavicles as an extra
pair of free hang ribs
no another way to think
of it conceptually
at least when it comes
to the terminology is
to think of the sternum
and manubrium as like
the torso and to think
of the SC joint, the
sternoclavicular
joint, as the shoulder
joint. Again, this is
just a conceptual model.
If that were the case,
then the clavicles
shown would represent
the upper extremity.
In this case, it would
look like the upper
extremities are abducted
90 degrees relative
to the torso of the
manubrium and sternum.
If you keep this
concept in mind then
the terminology of testing
for sternoclavicular
motion will make
better sense.
When you have a
patient actively shrug
their shoulders, the
sternum, excuse me,
the medial clavicle,
meaning the clavicle
that articulates with
the manubrium will
glide inferiorly and
if it does that well
and it does not rise
back superiorly when
the patient relaxes
the shoulder then
that is called an
abduction dysfunction
because again using the
image when they shrug
their shoulder they
will be raising the
distal part of the
clavicle and the
medial part of the
clavicle, meaning the SC
joint portion, will
be going inferiorly.
So if that is the
motion that they do
well and the medial
clavicle does not
rise back superiorly
when they relax their
shoulders, then it
would be known as,
for example, if
it's on the left
side, a left
sternoclavicular
abduction somatic
dysfunction.
If we take the next
scenario where the
patient depresses the
shoulder, we would expect
that the medial
clavicle at the SC joint
should glide superiorly.
And if it does that,
and you feel your
fingers, which are
monitoring on the superior
aspect of the medial
clavicle, you would
expect those to rise.
when the patient
depresses their shoulder.
If it does that,
but then when they
relax the shoulder,
it does not go
inferiorly, then we
would call that a SC
joint adduction
somatic dysfunction.
So if it were, for
example, on the
right side, then
we would call that
a right SC joint
adduction, that's
AD, adduction
somatic dysfunction.
Retraction of the
shoulder means that
the patient pulls
the shoulders
back. That causes the
medial part of the
clavicles to glide
anteriorly. Again,
think of this
reciprocal motion.
And you should feel
your fingers, which
are monitoring the
anterior aspect of the
medial clavicles to
move anteriorly. And if
it does that during
retraction and then
it glides back
posteriorly as they relax
their shoulders meaning
bring it back into
neutral position then
all is fine but if
it stays anterior then
whichever side does
that assuming it's
just one side to keep
it easy for now then
we call that side
as having an extension
somatic dysfunction
and then lastly when
we have the patient
protract the shoulders
we would expect the
medial part part of
the clavicles to go
posteriorly and if it
does that, meaning our
fingers again that are
monitoring the anterior
aspect of the medial
clavicle, go posteriorly
as the patient
protracts the shoulder
and then when they
bring the shoulder back
into neutral position,
we should feel the
medial clavicle go back
anteriorly, meaning
return to the more
anterior position.
It does not do that
and it stays stuck
posteriorly, then
we would call that
side a flexion,
a SC joint flexion
somatic dysfunction.
So if you think about
it, we are naming for
the freedoms as we
have been doing with
somatic dysfunction
diagnosis in other regions.
Here's a summary on
a sternoclavicular
joint glides I
just covered.
As you might imagine,
because of a lack of
any structure being
in the way, the most
common dysfunctions for
the SC joints are the
extension dysfunctions and
adduction dysfunctions.
That's AD, adduction
dysfunctions. And
keep in mind that,
again, in addition to
dysfunction being
possible on both sides,
meaning bilaterally,
it is also possible to
have a combination. So
for example, a patient
can have an extended
and adducted clavicle.
So if you were to
encounter that to minimize
confusion, first
decide on which is the
more significant one
and name it after that.
Then once you learn the
treatment, treat that
and then recheck it
and see what remains.
And then you can
perhaps diagnose another
dysfunction that might
be superimposed on
that original dysfunction
unless somehow
your initial treatment
was able to take
care of the combination
somatic dysfunction
here's some additional
information on
diagnosing the sc
joints keep in mind that
the sc joint is commonly
diagnosed actively
meaning the patient
moves the shoulder
but it can also be
done passively and
commonly they are
evaluated at the same time
but you can also
have a patient move
one side, for
example, and then have
them move the other
side and compare.
So just develop
flexibility in your
approach, and this will
allow you to better
diagnose patients
when the situation
calls for it. So
based on what I have
just described, you
should be able to go
through this table
on your own and
understand the various
descriptions here.
Next we come to the
acromioclavicular
joint, or AC joint
for short. As you can
see from the list here,
there are a number
of somatic dysfunctions
that one can
diagnose, and some
of them are more easy
to understand why
they're named that way,
such as internal and
external rotation.
Others less so. For
example, the abduction
and adduction somatic
dysfunctions, those
are not as immediately
clear until one
actually performs the
range of motion testing
that is required in
order to make that
diagnosis and since
the range of motion
testing involves
movement of the shoulder
joint itself then it
becomes clear why the
dysfunctions are named
accordingly so just
keep that in mind
as with the SC joint
the somatic dysfunction
is named for what
it prefers to do so
it is important to
understand that we are
naming for freedoms
but also be able to
understand that if it is
free in one direction
that that means
there is restriction
in the other direction
in terms of dysfunctions
it's good to note
that certain glides
go together so for
example if the ac joint
has an abduction somatic
somatic dysfunction
that goes with internal
rotation and superior
glide, and if it
is adducted, it goes
along with external
rotation and inferior
glide. So this is useful,
of course, not just
for testing purposes,
but also for when you
clinically evaluate
someone. So for example,
if you determine
that someone has clearly
an externally rotated
AC joint, but you
are less sure about
the other motions,
then if you understand
that these three
dysfunctions go together,
then you can reason
through that they most
likely will have an
adduction somatic dysfunction
as well as an
inferior glide. And by
knowing this, you can
go back and reassess,
and perhaps it will
become clearer to you.
And in terms
of assessing,
keep in mind, again,
patients might have
dysfunction on
both sides, and the
symptom will help
guide you. So if it's
a left-sided symptom,
then chances are
any dysfunction
that you find in the
AC joint will be most
likely on the left,
or at least that's
where you start.
And also keep
in mind that not
all abnormalities
that you palpate
are due to somatic
dysfunction.
A patient may have
previous injuries or
surgeries to explain
abnormal motion, and this
motion can also be a
lack of motion or even
lack of the joint if
they have had a AC
joint in this section
for example and in some
cases there might be
excessive mobility
so keep all of this in
mind as you make your
AC joint diagnosis
it is important to be
able to palpate this
joint well when you when
you assess so having
a finger to palpate
over the joint line
and typically this is
with the middle finger
and then your index
and your ring finger
will be on either side
of the joint on the
clavicle and acromion.
Here's a description
of passive
testing of the AC joint.
So the terminology
goes from palpating the
distal clavicle onto
the acromion. So
again, you're going
from medial to lateral
so with that in mind
if you have a somatic
dysfunction where
the distal clavicle
glides inferiorly
well and when you move
on to the chromium from
the distal clavicle
as though your
fingers were like feet
and you walk up to the
chromium because it
glides inferiorly
well but it does not
glide superiorly well
then it's as though
your fingers have to
step up or walk up from
the distal clavicle
onto the chromium.
In that case passive
motion testing
means that the distal
clavicle springs
easily in an inferior
direction and positionally
it's also inferior
to the chromium.
That's why it's called
an inferior glide
again referring to
the distal clavicle,
also known as a step
-up dysfunction at
the AC joint. The
opposite would be true if
it is a superior
glide of the AC joint,
referring again to
the distal clavicle,
then it is superior.
It does not want to
depress or move inferiorly,
so it would resist
springing, meaning
your fingers on top of
the distal clavicle
attempting to spring,
meaning to move the
distal clavicle in an
inferior direction.
So if it does not do
that well, then it is
a superior glide and if
your fingers move from
the distal clavicle
onto the chromium,
it's as though it is
stepping down because
the distal clavicle
relative to the chromium
is slightly higher.
Here are the
various maneuvers
you will be
practicing in lab
in order to
diagnose adduction,
abduction, as well
as associated motions
of the AC joint. So
on the left, we have
adduction and abduction
testing. The key
point with all of these
is to monitor over
the AC joint. Ideally,
you will have a finger
over the joint
itself, as well as on
each side of it, meaning
on a chromium and
on a distal clavicle.
And it is important
to be able to control
the elbow or the forearm
but holding it close
to the elbow. And
even though you are
moving the shoulder,
the key is to
see what motion
is occurring at
the AC joint.
And that is because
it is not easy or
practical to test for
these motions by holding
the AC joint and it's
just not possible to
be able to introduce
the motion sufficient
the motions of
sufficiently to be able
to diagnose these
dysfunctions at least not
in the way that we
are describing where
you really want to
test its ability to gap
for example in the
case of adducting the
elbow, meaning adducting
the shoulder because
they head in the same
direction. Adduction
of the elbow on the
bottom right also
adducts the shoulder,
and you would expect
that there would be a
gapping type motion.
So if it remains gap
and does not close,
then that would
be an adduction
dysfunction. And this
motion is associated
with inferior gliding
gliding of the
lateral clavicle,
as well as external
rotation. So there
are combined motions.
So even though this
shows adduction,
but by the way you're
holding it at the elbow,
you are also introducing
external rotation.
And then abduction
of the shoulder would
lead to closing off
of the joint of the
AC joint so if it
closes well but does not
open well during
adduction then that would
be an abduction
dysfunction so let me
repeat for the top right
if you're monitoring
over the AC joint
and you find that
there is the space it
does not open up well
during adduction as
shown on the bottom
right but when you
abduct it of course it
closes further or
simply remains closed
then that would lead
you to conclude that
there is a right ac
joint abduction ab
abduction somatic
dysfunction and this would be
associated with a
superior glide and
internal rotation
dysfunction to, most likely.
And you can see on
the top right that
abduction in the way
that it is shown here,
abduction of the right
shoulder leads to
superior glide of
the lateral clavicle
and also introduces
internal rotation. So
all of this will
become clearer in lab,
but keep in mind that
the way we're testing
actually involves
testing multiple types
of motions, including
the ability of the
AC joint to gap by
abducting the shoulder
or to close by
abducting the shoulder.
Again, we are using
shoulder motion
to introduce motion
into the AC joint.
And the other motions
listed here, the gliding
motions superiorly,
inferiorly, as well
as internal rotation
and external rotation.
Here's another
picture showing
internal and external
rotation testing
of the AC joint.
Again, you control
the upper extremity
well enough so
that you can
comfortably internally
and externally
rotate the patient's
shoulder enough for
you to gauge any
motion abnormality
in the AC joint.
It is important to
keep in mind that we
are not looking for the
limitation of motion
of the shoulder joint
itself but for the
AC joint so for
example if you were to
test say internal
rotation and you find a
barrier then you would
name that a right AC
joint external rotation
somatic dysfunction
because the barrier is
an internal rotation
it does not mean
that you can't if you
wanted to move the
shoulder as picture
here even further into
an internal rotation
but in that case you
will be going beyond
just testing the AC
joint. You will be
actually be testing
the glenohumeral joint
and even the scapulothoracic
articulation.
So it is important
to keep this
test localized
to the AC joint.
And even as shown
here, you can get some
sense of the gliding
motion of the clavicle.
normally it would
glide superiorly with
internal rotation and
inferiorly with external
rotation of the
shoulder and this motion
may be subtle and
how do you know if
it's enough motion or
or too much motion well
you do that based on
feeling a lot of ac
joints comparing it
to the other side and
also understanding it
from the perspective
of any history of trauma
surgery immobility
and so forth in the
patient's history
so it will tell you
will need to develop
clinical experience
to adequately decide
whether any motion
that you feel is within
normal limits or too
much or too little.
Lastly, we have diagnosis
of the
glenohumeral joint.
As you are probably
already aware, this
joint or proper
motion of this joint
is critical to most of
our daily functioning
because of the
use of our upper
extremity. And keep
in mind that there are
both major motions
and minor motions.
So the picture here
shows testing of
the minor motions
where the doctor
stabilizes the top of
the shoulder with one
hand while controlling
the upper arm
near the shoulder
with the other hand.
And even though there
are multiple directions
that one can test
for, the main motions
that we will test for
in terms of gliding
are anterior and
posterior gliding as well
as superior and
inferior gliding. Now to
illustrate the significance
of these gliding
motions, imagine
opening your dresser
drawer. It can
occasionally be stuck but
usually the solution is
simple. Of course you
can strong arm it and
try to force it into
opening or closing
but a better way and a
less likely to cause
damage kind of way
would be to slightly
shift the drawer and
then usually this takes
care of it and we can
open or close it after
that. So So that's
an illustration of how
minor gliding motions
can help the joint
be more anatomically
properly seated with
respect to the opposing
surfaces and allow
proper functioning.
So with osteopathic
evaluation,
we are interested,
of course, in
both the major
and minor motions,
but the picture here
shows specifically
assessment of the
minor motions.
Here's a table showing
the various, on
the right side column,
the various gliding
motions you can test
for. I think these
are relatively self
-explanatory. In terms
of the gross range
of motion of the
shoulder, the larger
motions, let's take the
top example for an
anterior or extension
somatic dysfunction
as the glenohumeral
joint extends or
abducts or externally
rotates the humeral
head moves anteriorly.
And for posterior
or flexion somatic
dysfunction of
the glenohumeral
joint, there is the
opposite motion of
the humeral head
moving posteriorly.
And you can review
this material on this
table and learn this
material and keep in mind
that with the major
motions come associated
more minor motions
and both are important
in the proper functioning
of the shoulder
there's some final points
proper functioning of
the ACSC and glenohumeral
joints all contribute
to proper functioning
of the shoulder.
Abnormalities of motion
of these joints can
generate pain, restrict
motion, and therefore
function, and potentially
even contribute
to impingement of other
structures such as
tendons in the rotator
cuff, for example,
nerves, and vasculature.
And lastly, motion
of these joints
is normal. So when
we say that there
is gliding motion,
for example associated
with adduction
and internal
rotation or excuse
me external rotation
of the shoulder at
the ac joint these
motions are normal but
it is only if there
is abnormality in
these motions meaning
too little or in
some cases too much
and also the fact
that it moves well in
one direction and not
the other those are
the ones that we end
up naming because
they are labeled as
being dysfunctional.
So once we
determine that it is
dysfunctional,
we name it based
on a convention
of freedoms.
Please take some time,
it shouldn't take
long, for you to
complete a worksheet to
test your understanding
of this material.
The answers will be
provided later in
the week of this
lecture. You do not
have to turn in
your answer sheet.
Thank you for
your attention.